en tout on ne sait pas si la liaison
elle se fait oui parce qu'en fait
c'était moi qui parlais ces portables
c'est bien fait j'ai toujours été
fasciné par les vents qui a les
hématophages en général et la naissance
de ses légendes
dracula c'est bien sûr le représentant
le plus connu d'entre eux mais la
question qui m'obsède le plus pourquoi
le sang pourquoi cette fascination
collective pour les vampires et qu'est
ce qui existe ou non dans tout ça alors
loïc générer des jeux
[Musique]
quand on a parlé de réaliser ce sujet il
ya presqu'un an aujourd'hui je ne savais
pas dans quelle direction j'allais aller
j'ai rencontré des spécialistes du sujet
jacques sirgent en une mémoire vivante
de l'histoire et des légendes et même
année matt hologue vincent cussac
ils ont accepté tous les deux de me
recevoir de discuter longuement avec moi
j'ai également demandé à l'équipe de
curieusement magazine dont le numéro 7
vient d'arriver
où va arriver dans vos boîtes aux
lettres de préparer un sujet dédié à
dracula l'immortel
le sujet est passionnant et complétera
cette vidéo que vous allez regarder ce
qui veut dire que vous pouvez si vous
souhaitez vous abonner dès aujourd'hui
pour le prochain numéro de curieuses ou
message vous en reparlerai à la toute
fin de la vidéo
[Musique]
les vampires se nourrissent de sang
puisque en tant qu'être mort il n'en
fabriquer eux mêmes et les croyances
disent aussi qu'ils ne supportent pas la
lumière du jour qui leur brûle la peau
et ça tombe bien il existe une vraie
maladie qui génère des oedèmes et des
cloques sur les patients qui ont le
malheur de croiser le soleil même que
quelques secondes
alors la proto porphyrie trop politique
c'est une maladie qui appartient à la
famille des ports finition des maladies
extrêmement à la proto porphyre être
politique elle couche contre un sur 75
mille âmes sur deux cent mille personnes
en fonction de la région du monde et du
type précis donc c'est extrêmement rare
par rapport à d'autres maladies l
hémophilie qui est ma spécialité touche
un garçon sur 5 mille naissances
vivantes et c'est déjà une maladie
extrêmement à les maladies de du groupe
mais paul cherry sont des maladies qui
peuvent toucher plusieurs organes en
particulier le système nerveux et la
peau il peut y avoir d'autres attentes
c'est une anomalie sans fin c'est un
groupe de maladies dont la nouvelle y
portent sur la fabrication de leyme
l'aiment
c'est essentiel pour la fonction du
globule rouge ce qui colore le sont en
rouge ça s'appelle l'hémoglobine
c'est l'association de molécules d'air
et de molécules de globine même dans sa
maturation
elle a besoin de comporter dû faire
c'est ce qui va d'ailleurs donné la
couleur rouge est ce qu'il va apporter
la fonctionnalité à l'hémoglobine dans
la proto porphyrie érythropoïétine qu'un
défaut de d'une enzyme qui est capable
d'apporter le faire dans l'aisne dans
toutes les maladies de la famille des
portiers rites sont des anomalies
souvent enzymatique qui vont jouer à
différents niveaux et qui vont conduire
à une qualité des mots qui n'est pas
celle attendue dans celle-ci
spécifiquement c'est c'est un problème
dans steam qui apporte le faire donc qui
donnera une hémoglobine en quantité
insuffisante une mauvaise qualité
c'est plaisant d'imaginer que peut-être
la proto porphyrie érythropoïétine plus
fréquente dans
pays de l'est dans les balkans a pu
inspirer le mythe du vampire en
particulier pour sa photo sensibilité du
coup je me suis posé la question est ce
que cette maladie ça trappe comme un
virus ou une bactérie ou c'est quelque
chose de génétique qu'on a à sa
naissance finalement une autre porte
chéri qui s'appelle la porphyrie trop
politique qui est aussi génétique et qui
peut avoir aussi des symptomatologie
commune une photo sensibilité mais
également une
une teinte des dans un petit peu rouges
brunes
alors ça avec des canines ne sont pas
allonger on peut qu'aller dans son rouge
dans la boîte aux ports série avait trop
politiques et des transmissions qu'on
appelle autosomique dominante ça veut
dire que la maladie est porté par des
chromosomes qui ne sont pas sexuel est
apportée par une seule copie faisait
connaître de notre génome en double une
moitié apportée par le pape a initié par
la maman la maladie dominantes sont
apportés par l'un des deux parents et on
est malade il ya des formes autosomique
récessive
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut que le papa
et la maman apporte une copie anormal
pour que les données soient dotés de
deux copies qui ne sont pas normales et
consomme malade il ya également des
formes dominantes lié au chromosome x
on a trouvé jusqu'à très récemment en
faisant un petit peu vidéographie tout
ça on avait trouvé jusqu'à très
récemment des gènes responsables de
poteaux pour thierry trop politique avec
des to qui tout petit pourcentage de
patients donc c'est une entité
voici donc des éléments qui pourrait
expliquer cette faiblesse du vampire ou
tout du moins en partie
c'est bien sûr de l'interprétation libre
mais avouez quand même que ce savoir là
il fascinant il ya plein d'autres choses
qui dérangent le vampire dans la vie il
ya plein d'autres éléments
caractéristiques de la lutte contre les
vampires et jacques nous donne une
lecture passionnante des possibilités de
pourquoi ça fait ça et où est-ce qu'on a
été piocher pour inventer ça il faut
inventer des contre feux
si les méchants c'est qui est forcément
des trucs pour pouvoir s'en défendre
l'ail est un médicament utilisé par les
égyptiens pour lutter contre les
morsures surtout de certains disent
campion morceaux de vampires ouais
pourquoi il aima pas l'ail et pourquoi
est-ce que dracula voir l'angleterre
dans le moment pascal il aurait pu
déménager dans n'importe quel pays
d'europe
saidal aux pays-bas mange mon oeil mais
le puits longueur l'a commencée en
pologne
scott une femme enceinte moore est
souvent par manque de soins les gens
avaient des remous tout fait ce qu'il
fallait donc qu'on en fasse un pull en
club où tu es à la fois le bébé et la
maman qui est pas les deux qui
reviennent tout c'est cohérent que parle
aux loups remporte le vampire est debout
pour lui l'abandon brrr c'est quoi le
monde pour les lignes souvent c'est le
prêt tout du kivu servait à conserver le
vampire pardon et quelle est leur idéal
pour un égyptien
c'est midi le soleil est au zénith et
vous pouvez pas vous cacher dans
l'enveloppé d'un pas lent parce qu'elle
va se cacher il est pur il a pas besoin
de se cacher pourquoi la voix de reflets
si le reflet souvent c'est ce que la
partie qu'on ne soit pas comme on est
devant puis on voit tel qu'il est c'est
vous pouvez l'homme dans le métro quand
vous regardez vos piles est pas trompé
puisqu'il est ce qu il il est simplement
pas alors d'où peut venir la naissance
du mythe des vampires est ce que ces
éléments ont créé l' être surnaturel
qu'on connaît ou est-ce que ces éléments
ont habillé des mythes qui existait sur
des noms mort et qu'on a personnifié on
a commencé à donner des détails un peu
comme des règles parce qu'elle était
basée sur quelque chose de vrai alors
dans l'histoire le vampire a remplacé un
petit peu la sorcière parce que là
c'était la sorcière qui était
responsable de tous les maux qui avec la
médecine il faut savoir que sorcellerie
et médecine déjà c'était c'était parfois
un petit peu connexion jusque jusque au
maule et nage je pense que les deux
étaient des comics même les sages femmes
étaient sorcières il ya des liens
évidents avec la médecine et puis on a
arrêté de s'occuper de s'attacher aux
sorcières pour pour des nouveaux mythes
et en particulier de vampires avec l'âge
d'or c'est vrai c'est le 19e siècle avec
avec dracula ou alors on a plaqué des
images offre c'est étonnant parce que
dans l'histoire du vampire on voit qu'en
fonction des époques dans des
civilisations
il ya des constantes l'image qu'on en a
maintenant elle est une image très
littéraire très romantique très 19e le
roman gothique l'homme enfermé dans sa
cape noire
les bains de sang les orgies il ya une
dimension très sexuel aussi dans le dans
le mythe du vampire capitale qui n'a
aucun rapport avec la question est mato
hématologiques vos persos sont aux
moeurs les femmes perdent leur sang est
un geste en lui l'homme préhistorique du
flipper en voyant ses compagnes tout de
lui rester vivante alors quelques uns
des morceaux du congo d'où le fait que
les femmes étaient diabolisés de très
tôt alors qu'on croyait parcours diam
on leur donnait à pouvoirs surnaturels
qu'on leur connaissait pas parce que les
femmes ont toujours été considérés comme
des des créatures inférieur dès
l'antiquité grecque
donc en profiter la force physique de
l'homme pour écraser les femmes alors
qu'on savait qu'elle avait une super
vite et morale donc le sens on buvait
l'eau est impropre à la consommation
on a commencé à boire ils sont très vite
pour des raisons ont donné du sens au
lieu des sacrifices animaux les aztèques
quand on off du sang radieuse c'est pas
une image il le bois qui est critiquée
tient que essaie d'inverser la tendance
que l'inflation normative obs crise
c'est quand vous buvez leçons des crises
mini mortels mais ils ont quand même
emprunté savoir beast c'était la
première croyances le premier rituel
qu'on offre un dieu premier sacrifice
c'est ça la vie décente donc le vampire
c'est la première croyances pour moi
c'est vieux c'est remonter des sens et
demi d'années avant un mois avant
jésus-christ d'ailleurs il ya l'inconnue
je crois que c'est peut-être mieux c'est
nyad qui a dit on juge de la qualité
d'un peuple par ses rapports avec les
morts quand on à reprendre l'immense
nestea qui sort ils ont ils seulement et
non sur des murs sont des banquiers dont
compliqué qu'on peut juger la qualité
d'appel par ses rapports avec les
vampires pour ça que ça ratisse très
large comme tel lorsque l'on creuse dans
l'histoire de dracula au sens de ses
inspirations
on s'approche très vite des fascinante
histoire des pays de l'est la roumanie
qui existe depuis dix neuvième siècle
seulement était un conglomérat de
provence qui étaient sous la domination
des habsbourg les autrichiens puis après
des mots turc
donc en gros chacun voulait récupérer la
roumanie est servi le plus de morts là
où il ya plus de morts c'est là où l'on
pût de quoi ils souvent pire très
souvent les mots les intérêts pas
quelquefois l'oeuf la l'armée ennemie
laisse l'armée vaincue intéressement des
parts et les corbeaux les mange
ils sont et pourrissent le dis à mort
qui n'est pas de sépulture ça remonte
aux grecs aux égyptiens va en enfer ou
dit un vampire
là où il ya le plus de morts et plus de
300 pompiers s'est pas spécialement
propre aux peuples aux mains s'il y
avait autant de massacres en france
c'est l'armée saxons qui étaient
massacrés par charlemagne
là aussi qu'on vaut bien forcément c'est
d'espoir le ventoux quand vous savez que
le nom de la personne que vous aimez les
montures choses me paraissent aussi de
dio vous allez imaginer quelque chose
qui permet de te d'avoir un peu d'espoir
aux pour moi le vent pied cet espoir
c'est que je 200% positif au final
pourquoi le vampire ça fascine autant là
aussi j'ai cent des mes invités en
essayant de trouver une ou des réponses
à ce côté magnétique du noctambule parce
que si dans la fiction il un pouvoir de
fascination
j'ai bien l'impression que ce pouvoir
fonctionne aussi dans l'attrait du grand
public pour cette légende
j'allais dire vivante un peu vivante un
peu quand on imagine pattinson dans
twilight focus a beau pour les réseaux
commercial mais il ya une autre raison
aussi il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
étaient ancrées vigan la médecine
moderne souvent niée ça parce qu'en mots
c'est pas très joli bond on donne des
coups de pieds ou des le croque mort
hein et puis on enterrait donc quelqu'un
qui est intelligent il meurt très très
vite
tant qu'il peut pas revenir par contre
les nobles qui sont elles dans les
caveaux quelques feuilles cercueil qui
dans une pièce si enterrés vivants et le
poids peut-être ouvrir son cercueil puis
moura et que fait ou de femmes parce
qu'il y aura personne venir le manger de
gros mots il ya aussi cette raison là
qui font que les premiers vente katic
and out sont des aristocrates
c'est pour ça que je dis ce qui est beau
on laisse parler son coeur on trouve des
solutions sepa sepa culturel c'est ça
vient du coeur comme levante
puisqu'aucune avec un plus dans leur
mine de rien cette route où la solution
est là où tu sais capacité d'aimer
justement qu'elle n'a pas d'armes mais
en pas d'armes il échappe à langoat du
jugement dernier
qu'est ce qui intéresse du et illies
abcès dame du diable pourquoi j'ai pas
d'âme
menacé par contre ne pas avoir une arme
pourrait faire de moi un monstre non
puisque les hackers et je préfère le
coeur à l'âme
je trouve que l'âme d'une invention des
anciens pour nous de venir justement
s'en amusait très bonne forme et cela
promet un capture qui peut dire le vôtre
brawn ou dues à des apps qui va sur
terre autour des gens qui l'aiment et
comme il est brillant on a discuté ça
peut être parfois être très joli gâteau
le vampire quand ils vous moi ou denis
mortelle alors qu'elle tue par des gens
crèvent avant l'âge de 50 ans jusqu'au
10 mg 10 quand même un cadeau mais comme
ça fait peur beaucoup de gens au
gouvernement aux religions place ils ont
cherché donne une image négative le 1er
janvier négatif
mes chances et dracula mais de reclasser
pas avoir si métaphore politique de
l'angleterre et bram stoker et irlandais
il est quand même bon de son bouquin
donc il va mettre dans chaque page effet
la première traduction intégrale tant
que la pulga lima en 2014 je vois chaque
magie même qu il s agit d écouter les
grands empires lisez entre les lignes de
ce qui est politique et égaux mais voilà
donc et comme il est convaincant dracula
depuis dracula les plans malheureusement
on a toujours vu ça même les odeurs
corporelles
malgré tout on se reconnaît et c'est
extrêmement érotique le sang et érotique
donc le le dracula en tout cas dans sa
dans sa façon d'avoir été écrit une
dimension érotique et maintenant ça
appartient au mythe du vampire ça a été
intégré ça n'était pas à l'origine
comme vous l'avez constaté plus on a
parlé du sujet plus cette
personnification de dracula en lui-même
est revenu dans nos conversations mais
en vrai c'est un autre sujet qui est
presque pas lié au vampirisme dracula
comme je vous le disais au début de la
vidéo j'ai un dossier de 10 pages sur
dracula qui va sortir dans le prochain
numéro de curieuses son magazine mensuel
qui sort en novembre
voici d'ailleurs une partie du sommaire
pour info l'abonnement est à partir
d'environ 1 0 65 par mois frais de port
inclus c'est moins cher qu'un tube sur
twitch est plus intéressant qu'un type i
puisque vous recevez durant un an 10
magazines de plus de 50 pages dans votre
boîte aux lettres et ou en version
numérique vous avez le lien pour ça dans
la description qui vous permettra en
plus de lire quelques pages d'avoir des
articles gratuits des anciens numéros et
si vous avez des questions toujours sur
ce même site
vous avez une effet que très solide et
vous avez un mail on n'est rien
merci à mes deux invités vincent reja
qui ont accepté de parler avec moi sous
l'oeil de la caméra
c'était passionnant j'avais envie de
tout mettre peut-être un jour je ferai
une vidéo non répertorié avec tout parce
que c'est allé un peu dans tous les sens
après on est un peu sorti aussi des
discussions vampires pour des
discussions plus scientifique ou plus
sur la philosophie les légendes mais
bref je les remercie énormément
vous trouverez plus d'infos sur dans la
description comme les livres de jacques
par exemple n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner à cette chaîne c'est gratuit
activer la cloche pour ne pas rater la
prochaine vidéo ici je vous mets une
vidéo sur l'incroyable chasse aux
trésors de la chouette d'or en france et
ici une vidéo on vous raconte nos plus
gros échec pour voir si on pouvait en
tirer quelque chose
j'espère que prochain numéro de
curieuses vous plaira autant que les
précédents
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt ciao